Hello, everybody.
It's time.
We're going straight in.
Whoa.
Okay.
What's this?
Half-Life 3?
On the PlayStation?
Exclusive by... Exclusive to the PlayStation?
What is this?
We're going straight in.
Straight into it.
Every time the sun dies, time stretches and tears.
See, the play does not wait for nobody.
There's no host here.
There's no what's his name.
name.
The Gamer Award host.
It's a stop bus.
Skyrim?
Skyrim on the PlayStation 6?
Scan for Sultari signals.
Signal corrupted.
Oh, yeah.
Jeff.
Yeah.
No, Jeff, to stop us.
To give us a five-hour intro before the trailer.
Confirmed.
You better stay out of my way.
Hey, everyone.
How's it going?
I'm Gregory Loudon.
I was like, oh, my God, that Jeff how smart today we are thrilled to show off this first look of gameplay for saros running on ps5 saros builds on returnals award-winning action oh it's returnal and haunting story returnal was fun i actually like returnal of carcoso it's basically for those who never it was exclusive on um uh playstation but then you know like all excuses uh it comes on a pc like one year later
um and it's actually really fun because it's basically like a shooter toho yeah i think i feel like if it was originally on the pc the game would have been a lot more popular like all exclusive games oh it's the volume two down okay i'll turn it down actually why am i turning down from here i'll turn it down oh yes you can now hit back hard using by holding the adaptive trigger on yeah it's a shooter roguelike toho it's very fun i really i remember really wanting to play it when it first came up but like getting uh getting like the rights to play the perms to play it was so hard so it never happened mark it on the map so i just played it off stream where you can learn more about lost
like getting perms back then for any PlayStation game requires like applying like one to two months in advance and it was for each session and like I and then like sometimes still sometimes we'll never even get the perms and I just gave up it was like an application too and so I was at that fuck this yeah and
like we couldn't monetize those streams too so i was just like applied months and events and i can't monetize like i'm like that's a lot of streams that i can't monetize that's this is second chance where you can be revived on first step to get straight back into the action but like that doesn't matter it doesn't matter we have fair use laws
I'm a bit okay not gonna lie this being the first trailer isn't like making me very excited about you know usually it's like first trailer they they put like the second most hype game and then it's like second most hype game as first trailer then most hype game play we're looking forward to revealing more on our mysterious so i'm a little worried just a little bit just a little bit next year is when you'll be able to play saros on ps5 and enhance the ps5 thanks for watching we can't wait to share more from all of the team working on saros
oh my god you think you'll announce silk saw the playstation
It's a fun game.
I just I wish it was more popular It's sad that because it was a PlayStation exclusive And not on the PS5 It didn't get the popularity it deserved Because it is a very, it's a solid game
So I was like, so I was like This game does look good, not gonna lie Also, uh, sound guy I turned down the, I turned the volume a little bit Let me know if I should turn down the volume more
Uh, Luca, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Fanny, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Also, I will say Mega Bonds is a fucking dangerous game.
It's...
Did you know Mega Bonds was developed by one guy?
It's so dangerous.
I...
I usually don't play solo games off stream.
But, like, it got me.
I went to bed at six in the morning because I was I spent like three hours on it.
I was about to head to bed.
I was like, you know, I'm going to do one more run.
And then three hours passed.
It was not one run.
We'll do what we always do.
Throw more assets at the problem.
We have plenty more.
Bring it down a little bit more.
All right, sound guy, brought it down a little bit more.
Also, like, it's the final boss.
They're planning on nerfing the final boss.
This is actually the most bullshit thing I've ever...
What the fuck is going on?
Is this...
Does it just go Elysium?
Long range missiles get results.
I heard this game is...
Really good.
Um...
But like...
I think the funny thing is like...
People who have no idea what this Elysium is...
They'll start playing it.
Oh, it's not.
The Zero...
Zero...
Pair...
Pairdus?
Oh, it is not the Scoliseum.
The people who don't really know what the Scoliseum is, they start playing it, and then, and then, like, they'll say some really crazy shit, and then they never, they don't continue it.
Because they don't...
Yeah, because apparently it's, like, extremely political, because they don't know exactly what it is.
So, like, when they get to that part, they just stop playing.
Uh, thanks.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Oh, it's Flight Simulator.
We have very good track record when it comes to fly.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
I can fucking fly with the zebras?
Wait, I wonder what happens if I, like, crash.
Microsoft Flight Simulator 2024.
Wait.
There's no...
no way that's yeah i was gonna say there's no way a microsoft game is exclusive to the playstation i'll be like holy did they just buy xbox like did they find did they win did they finally won the war i was gonna be like oh my god they won the console wars imagine like microsoft flight simulators exclusive to the playstation three two execute the world as it's commonly known has crumbled alliance oh battlefield hey guys um i have a ea code i still forgot to tweet about how did i have an ea creator code guys it's toky bird if you want to pre-order battlefield and use my code.
I still forgot about it.
It just takes a little shake of perspective.
Oh,
the sound guy brought it down a little bit.
I know if I should adjust the volume again.
Where's the defib?
Excuse- Oh, I know this room.
doctor that's my office right there i know that place like the back of my hand that's the doctor's office of course you that's a deep bedroom hey everyone i'm sean benson and i'm sid shuman sean and i are back to share news and release dates for games coming to ps5 but first thanks to ea definitely thank you for the hundred bitties thank you thank you October 10th on PS5.
Oh, October.
Wait, that's so soon.
Now, let's celebrate so many good games coming out.
Within, like, the next couple of months is actually crazy.
I heard the reviews came in for Hades, too, and it's, like, nine and, or, like, tens to nines.
This PS5 remaster is a collaboration between Idos Montreal and Aspire.
The studio behind remastered classics like Tomb Raider and Soul Rebirth.
It sucks because I still need to finish silk sawing.
I really want to I really want to try Hades too.
But I have to finish Silk Song first.
I told myself, like, I'm doing one series a week.
Two series is just too much.
There's just so many good games.
There's so many good games coming up.
No two playthroughs unfold the same.
Deus Ex Remastered arrives on PS5 early next year.
I'll just wait for the PC version.
It's almost Halloween.
Wait for the PC.
I'm sorry.
But yeah.
I don't think the remastered is worth playing on the console.
Halloween the game?
The team at Ilphonic invites players to an asymmetrical horror sandbox where you can play as a civilian survivor.
Oh, it's Dead by Daylight.
But like...
But Halloween.
Or to hunt them down as Michael Myers.
He possesses unique abilities.
It's literally, it's dead by daylight formula.
I'm pretty sure.
It's like the chainsaw massacre.
It's Friday at 13.
Yeah, it's Friday at 13.
That's like these games are really fun.
But like, people like just don't have enough friends to make it to keep it alive.
Oh my god, it's literally Friday at 13.
It's actually Friday the 13th.
Protect his victims when Halloween the game launches on September 8th, 2027.
It's the same animation.
Wait, it's actually just...
It's just a reskin of Friday the 13th.
Friday the 13th.
First, their hit action RPG, last epoch.
But we're in the suburbia instead of the camp.
This celebrated dungeon crawler.
Yeah, they're gonna lose their rights in one year.
Yeah, I think they reskinned it.
It actually has the same animation.
I better be able to...
The Katy Perry dance.
California girls.
I better not be able to do...
They better reskin that too.
The last epoch's first major expansion, Orobus, will arrive at the same time as the upcoming PS5 release.
I love the Also, I love Whenever, okay, I think it was Kony And he was like Dead by Daylight is just tag And like, everything clicked for me I was like, that's why I don't like Dead by Day It's just It's just tag It's just spooky tag And play an original story You can experience only in the game Capture a creature go fishing apparently there's like okay I don't understand like isn't the objective as the killer to kill all the survivors because apparently being killer right now is miserable because you have to do like this little like inside like there's little like rule thing with the survivors where you have to let them survive a little like long enough then you can kill them because the survivors will get yeah they're fucking made up rules and then um january 28th yeah no they were yeah apparently then the game devs were like okay if you kill the survivors too early we're gonna give you a warning i'm like what isn't that the point of the game like for them to not survive and then
like you know there was like backlash about it but then get mad if you like don't let them live a little longer.
Oh my God, Mega Man!
Proto Man!
Oh my God, Sonic Racing has everything.
Familiar sights and sounds will take players back to some of Mega Man's most memorable adventures.
Cause like survivors will actually like rage quit or like slur at you if you like kill them too early.
And I'm like, but the game is all, if you are a killer, You're supposed to kill!
I don't understand!
What's the point of being?
What's the fun of it?
You can't kill.
Like...
I don't understand.
Including a release date for Neo 3.
If kill...
If killer...
Why no kill?
Who will be Shogun?
Kure Matsu.
Why?
What's this?
You never understand what it means!
Is this Onimusha?
I am Himiko on my honor as a samurai warrior Neo 3 There's so many samurai type games I feel like I could name like 5 That that's come That's a sequel that's coming out There's so many samurai sequels coming out Like this year and next year So it's hard to figure out which samurai game it is To rule One must prove their might.
Guys, thank you for the tier one song.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Japanese silk song.
There's actually so many.
Like Neo, Neo, Samurai Warriors, Onimushu.
And what was the ghost of Yotai?
Yotai?
And they're all like sequels coming out.
Neo.
I always wanted to play Neo.
That's also a very long series too.
There's so many series.
Dynasty Warriors!
Yay!
This was worth it.
This state of play was worth it.
Oh my god!
Is this a remaster of the best Dynasty Warriors game?
That's classic Talion!
Oh my god, this is a remaster!
Oh!
have okay it was worth it the state of it's state of play this is actually the one of the better best versions my my manager please say oh my god it's just like please play this no no okay dynasty warriors 3 is not that long okay it's not a very long game it's actually very short compared to like the other dynasty warriors games from existence unless i decide to play each character
because each character has its own story so unless i decide to do each character for its own story our current world
What's Code Vain?
The tampering with history is strictly forbidden.
Is it...
Oh, it's anime, Dark Souls.
Oh, yeah, I remember.
We remember they...
I...
It's the same thing I asked last time.
I remember now.
I asked this before last time, too.
Today you'll pay your dues!
Boom, boom, boom!
Boom, boom!
The music is pretty hype.
Code Fane.
I wonder if there's going to be any...
Uh, any like...
Back in June, we debuted Final Fantasy XI's exclusive first looks.
Right here on State of Play.
The Dynasty Warriors one was pretty hyped though.
That one actually made me so happy.
I think like 3 and 4 were the best.
Was it 3?
3 was one of the best ones.
There was one where I really liked where each character has its own story.
Okay.
We'll be fucked up if I just like watch something else.
I was like, oh, Final Fantasy Tactics?
Alright, let's watch something.
Don't you dare.
Let's do a quick run on MegaBug while they talk about file fantasy tactics.
I see your words for what they are.
Skip ad!
Come on, thank you for your one sub, thank you!
Yay!
You see, it has to work tactics and then my brain turns off.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
Uncle Def and Shin Hida Yuki.
Let it die?
What's let it die?
This game is a extraction shooter.
It's an extraction shooter.
Yeah, it's extraction melee.
I just, I just, I can't.
I, I don't know.
Extraction, anything related to extraction is just...
I think it's just the losing your material stuff that messes with me.
Because I'm like, if I never play, I never lose my stuff.
Nope.
If I never play, I'll never lose it.
Just don't die.
It's the easiest way to never die.
I mean, it looks really fun.
Let it die, Inferno.
It looks fun.
It's just hard because Tarkov just has such a grip on the extraction shooter genre.
that's, like, been able to compete against it.
They have just a, like, they just have it in their fucking hand and they're like, I'm never letting you go.
Like, you can never leave me.
Oh, it looks pretty.
I feel like, okay, it looks really pretty, but also, like, it's so hard to see.
I think, like, judge, looking at this, it looks incredibly hard to see because there's just so many lines.
Yeah, I think it's very unique, but I can't see anything, too.
You know what?
It's like, yeah, visual clutter.
Yeah, I was going to say it.
It's just so cluttered.
And, like, I guess, like, because he's red, he's red, so then that's like a way to defend differentiate from the rest of the background.
But even then, that's so much visual.
.
I think so.
It looks like a platform in Metrovania.
The endless.
I mean, it says endless.
All right, pa-pa-pa-pa.
Citizens of Pi-well.
Today, three more minutes of trailers.
... by our own hand.
...
We fight those who wield power to prey on the weak.
Beasts who think themselves men.
That is what it means to be a Greymane.
What's Crimson Desert?
The time has come to do what we believe to be right.
Yeah, they said it's only 30 minutes, right?
Seek out your Greymane comrades.
Wait, is that John Snow?
It looks like him.
And let your heart speak without fear.
Single player Black Desert.
I know Black Desert was really, is really, is a really popular memo.
We fight for the future of all.
Surround the horde of our final battle.
It looks really good.
Oh shit.
Your fight is not for revenge, nor glory, nor pride.
Oh my god, there's mechas!
Just a random mecha floating in medieval, like medieval times.
Why the fuck would I get a mecha if I have a fucking dragon?
Dragon's just freaking bloat.
Like, it can fly faster than whatever the fuck that was.
The ye old mecha.
A dragon can just melt the mecha.
In desktop.
Pulse elevate.
Wireless speakers.
Skip ad.
Not game.
It's almost like in town, I was like, wait, I thought it was a PS5.
What if a place with speakers, though?
I don't know.
I feel like, who plays with speakers these days?
Don't call me out.
I guess for couch.
Oh, that's true.
If you have, like, friends to invite people over.
That's, I forgot about that.
Wait, friends come in IRL too?
You mean they're not all online?
Alexa, turn off the lights.
Alexa, turn off the TV.
Hi, everyone.
Offline friends?
Friends are real people.
They're just not just mom and dad.
with Planar Magnetic Drivers and PlayStation Link wireless technology.
Visit PlayStation Blog for...
Alexa, subscribe to Doki Bird on Twitch.
Now, let's check in on what's next for PlayStation Plus.
Up first is the October monthly games lineup.
The creepy and captivating Alan Wake 2 arrives just in time for spooky season, with Goat Simulator 3 and Cocoon rounding out the list.
These all arrive for PlayStation Plus essential numbers on the channel.
Twitch's video is not supported.
Stop saying, Alexa.
Yeah You remember me oh my god the last of us The part of my god we're getting more remasters Oh wait what you're thrilled to confirm the addition of the last of us part two to the PlayStation plus Okay, I was gonna say oh my god another I cannot wait for my fifth remaster of the last of us For PS5 members this includes the last of us part 2 remastered the definitive way to experience Ellie and Abby story like the roguelike survival mode no return.
Our update to the PlayStation Plus Classics catalog is extra exciting for fans of fighting games and the number three.
Tekken 3 from the original PlayStation and Soul Calendar 3 from the PS2 are coming to the service later this year.
Also arriving this year, another all-time classic from the PS2, Tomb Raider Anniversary.
Yay!
And up next, a special message from the creator of PlayStation's most iconic franchises.
Bloodboard?
Oh.
This is not their most iconic.
I was like, what?
I'm gonna cry from this day.
I was like, wait, iconic?
He was like, cars?
Stop bloodboard chart.
Most iconic immediately card slot.
There's no way they're ending this on cars.
There's no way.
100 million units sold?
People really fucking love cars, man.
Oh, thank God.
I was going to say, I swear to God, if they end on cars, I swear to God.
Oh, they just end on a controller.
I mean, that's...
I don't know if that's equally as disappointing
more yeah they end on a controller actually no i take it back i wish they ended on cars i wish they ended on cars oh thank god thank fucking god that might have been worse what longer than i can remember
I'd like to say I'm not a violent man Okay, how short is he, though?
Is he, if he's short, then like they know what they're doing
He's supposed to be like, what, 5 foot 4 or some shit He better be like 5 foot 2 He better be tiny He better be the shortest one in this game I'm sorry, Sony
you short king the original short king that's always waiting just
not for me oh my god it looks so good i mean it's by insomniac so like it better be good i want to play the spider-man game so badly
if he's over five foot two not my oh my god no hero mystique
oh my god it looks so good thank god they actually ended it with a real game thank fucking god i was gonna be like i i swear to god this this state of play ends with a goddamn god a word controller i
the question that comes up to us at zombie games is are you going to make a wolverine game that is as violent as visceral as the character in the comics I think it I mean spider-man was a a PlayStation exclusive effort so I won't be surprised working with Wolverine is interesting because people have been talking about this game for so long because they're like is it actually gonna come out narrator he has gaps in his memory so Wolverine doesn't really remember a lot of his life and that's got to be an experience it has to be because like the spider-man one was all of rage and fury but that was exclusive time and he could be very very kind and tender i feel like this entire state of play it was just to hype this they were like we finally finished the trailer they're like all right we got okay stand play tomorrow i feel like that was basically like all right we need to find things to pass the we need to find some stuff to pass the state of play to announce wolverine i feel like that's
basically it like because like everything else was like what the and then wolverine with something samiak ourselves we all agreed he's the one we don't need to see anybody else hey i'm leon mcintyre and i play james logan howlett in marvel's wolverine that that's not bad that one sort of works oh my god he sounds sort of like who he is oh what's his name try and find the essence of who wolverine is he sort of sounds like it yeah he sounds like you yeah people take from him people betray him he still fights for people who can't fight themselves you yeah he sounds like you jackman life one of the biggest responsibilities i've ever had and one of the coolest things i've ever got to do the entire game is built around staying true to the wolverine experience and then how do we want to put our insomniac stamp on that how do we want to put our own spin and creativity but still give something new and fresh that fans are going to be excited about it's the full package it is a level of detail
that we've never been able to do before jesus it's so gory you can see pours you can see blood in between the little lines of his teeth i love the attention to detail it's exciting that we're going to be able to bring that kind of fidelity to players it's so boring invited goes to many places but like that's basically wolverine he's literally like slashing you with his fucking does sliding down that rooftop and you can see that looks so good and low town it's always nice teasing the depth and the amount of characters that we'll be seeing there and there are some hints to other characters that fans of wolverine will recognize for sure like i swear to god if there's no way they don't include saber too blood he's literally like his rival pretty phenomenal there's a part in the trailer where logan jumps down and then he does the claws up through the face that one i thought maybe was going to be taking it too far but i am so glad that we have it it looks fantastic wolverine's combat making
that special making that feel like him making it feel different to anything else you've played that's a tough job what's so cool for me is there was this one section would you say they're marvel rival so incredibly satisfying i was like this is gonna be amazing we're pretty excited about the artwork that we're using on the cover it's dynamic it's rough edged you notice it doesn't look like our past games it has a sense of urgency and forward movement and rage and fury and that's wolverine yeah i i'm like i don't think peter parker could do any of that i ever worked with make you feel part of their team that's not something you always get we've been in a creative collaboration with insomniac games and playstation for over a decade now we've made some of the greatest superhero games of all time and that was always the goal we made some greatest superhero games all time Spider-Man.
I mean, one game.
All Spider-Man.
On behalf of everyone at Insomniac Games and the Wolverine team especially, we want to thank you for taking time to watch our trip.
And Spider-Man 2.
Spring of 2026.
One game three times.
And they are right.
the fact that it's like a year i swear i i feel like they like finished the trailer and then literally sony was just like say to play tomorrow i don't care what you padded with we have to announce a state of play like this is our end our end trailer
Like, all the other games, other than Dynasty Warriors 3, was like, why are we watching this?
Because, like, a lot of these games have already been announced before.
Like, we know, like, I feel like 70% of these games that's being shown have been shown already in previous state of plays.
So I was just like, wait, what?
Again?
That was fun.
That was like, okay.
Like the last trailer actually like fucking saved the entire state.
That last trailer and Dynasty Warriors 3 saved the entire state of play.
Because I remember everyone was like talking about like, oh, do you think the Wolverine project is still going to be a thing?
Because like there was like no news about it for so long.
There's been no news about the Wolverine game.
in a very long time so people were like wait are they like still gonna be doing it or is it not cancelled and then bam there it is finally it's no longer rumors we're finally we're finally getting wolverine uh yeah like people fly was cancelled too so they're like nope it's not cancelled just gotta wait a year here it is um but yeah no i think i'm really looking for forward to the new Wolverine game.
I have always wanted to play the Spider-Man game for a while now.
I just, you know, like I said, there's just so many games to play and I'm always like, okay, I'll play this and I'll play that and I'll play this.
So I'm bouncing around between a lot of game series, but definitely would love to do Spider-Man before Wolverine comes out.
Oh yeah, the Wonder Woman game too that I think like officially got canceled.
I remember reading, I'm not sure if that's also, uh, rumors, but I heard, uh, I heard the Wonder Woman game got officially canceled, so, um, not 100% sure, but I read about it, uh, which is very unfortunate.
Uh, I feel like DC doesn't have, I mean, yeah, DC doesn't have any good games other than, What was it?
What was the fighting game that they did?
I forgot what it was called, but other than that.
And Batman, Arkham Knight, yeah.
Other than Arkham, yeah.
Injustice.
It's Injustice and Arkham that they really have.
Now all they have is like that phone game trip.
Like that weird ass DC phone game that keeps fucking playing those like fake YouTube.
I don't know I don't even know what game it is It's like a civilization simulator thing And that was like the only DC game Yeah the ad game Yeah that's like the only DC game That's currently out recently right now And like all the other I remember they made this Arkham Knights Is that what it's called?
There was one with the Robins and stuff That they try to do But I also failed.
I feel like it's because they always all try to do like this weird-ass like open world, like open world game.
But like it's not really that open.
Oh, Gotham Knights.
Yeah, I heard that Gotham Knights was pretty bad.
And there was also Suicide Squad where they like killed off all the Justice League.
And then everyone got really mad.
And then and then they're like, Tiki, JK, they weren't actually dead dead.
Those were their clones.
But people were like.
Hmm.
You're like, hmm.
Yeah.
Okay, buddy.
Sure it was.
Except, yeah, everyone's actually still alive.
We just killed off the clothes.
I'm like, wait, what about Wonder Woman?
Didn't she die?
So she died for nothing?
Like, I'm just thinking, wait, so Wonder Woman died for nothing?
Like, people were like, okay, they had to have Done, they, like, Literally, like, done a Patch, live, live patch Fix of it, because I think originally They were meant to They were meant to be Dead, dead, but then the backlash Was so bad that they were like,
okay, we gotta Fix this, alright, JK, they're all Clones, every one of them, but Not Wonder Woman, we don't care about that, every one Of them were clones, and then, like, Cause, like, they made, like, instead of, like, an actual cutscene of it they like drew like it was just still images of the story they're like they just drew the pictures they just illustrated it i'm like wait okay so if this was planned why the fuck does it not have an animated cutscene like why is it just like screenshots i yeah it was like a slideshow i was like wait then why didn't you have an actual animated cutscene if Like,
it was planned.
Yeah, it was like slideshow and text.
And then they don't address the fact that Wonder Woman died.
They're like, everyone was clowns.
The Justice League had no female member.
I was just like, what?
There's never been a female member in the Justice League.
Everyone else was...
It's all just been Batman, Superman, Green Lantern, Flash.
That's it.
An Aquaman.
There was no woman, wonder who?
There was no wonder woman.
Wonder who?
Yeah, that's crazy.
I was like, what the fuck?
But yeah, I was surprised.
of that game because like i think um i think the worst part about it honestly with suicide squad is how they handled batman because like um it was like the batman voice actors like not his last role but like one of his last roles and everyone was so excited because you know it was supposed to be like um a sequel to the arkham series and then they're like what the they're like they didn't oh my god they did it too dirty yeah i didn't that so i it wasn't his last role as batman it wasn't kevin conroy's last role as batman it was like like his second or third last role um yeah i think his second last role as batman and people got real i i look you got like i feel like like they in hindsight they should have like i don't know delay the game a little bit and fix that
like i was just like thinking like oh my god they should put that in development health it's very i i think it's a little yeah it was definitely a little insulting um yeah it's such a terrible standoff to um a beloved like voice actors and like the character the batman character um anyway guys uh that was a fun watch along i hope you guys enjoyed i do have another stream and i have to prep for it because it is a sponsor stream um but uh uh you can uh if you guys like to watch more of me you're new here my name is joki bay i usually stream on youtube and actually have another stream in two hours uh on youtube for nikki so please check me out over there um if you like my content um you want to know whenever i stream on twitch please follow me on twitter because i usually tweet out whenever i stream on twitch um you want to support me via other means please feel free to check out uh all my merch stuff so merchandise helps a lot my doki merch my collab with gina draws ends today so you
guys want to grab anything from my apparel collection um please feel free to check out my gina draws apparel collab um because pre-orders ends today and it'll be gone forever uh anyway guys thank you all for the subs for the follows for the bitties um as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.